ah
[Música]
i
la ola de calor extremo que azota el
oeste de eeuu podría resultar todavía
más peligroso y es que este calor
extremo se une además a la sequía que
arrastra esta zona del país desde hace
años y que se teme que podría que ambas
cosas podrían resultar en mega incendios
como los que se han vivido en años
anteriores y que han destruido cientos
de miles de hectáreas y dejado cientos
de muertos en algunas ciudades de
california se han llegado incluso a los
50 grados de temperatura mientras que
otras partes muchísimo menos
acostumbradas a ver estas altas
temperaturas como seattle y portland que
están al norte de california se han
llegado incluso al derretir cables de
tranvía y a romper partes del asfalto
debido a este calor los efectos perdón
los expertos están llamando a este
fenómeno cúpula de calor y aseguran que
se debe sobre todo al cambio climático
las autoridades tanto en california como
en washington y en el estado de oregón
están pidiendo a los residentes que
intenten no salir a realizar demasiadas
actividades al aire libre los días de
máximas temperaturas mientras
están habilitando centros con aire
acondicionado
[Música]
la ola de calor ha pegado fuerte en los
estados del norte de méxico el pasado 18
de junio mexicano y capital de baja
california registró el calor más intenso
desde 1948 al alcanzar el termómetro de
los 50 y 1.4 grados centígrados en esa
ciudad el calor ha cobrado la vida de
seis personas entre ellas un inmigrante
guatemalteco en otras ciudades como
hermosillo capital del fronterizo estado
de sonora el termómetro también ha
batido récords al superar los 46 grados
centígrados en contraste otros estados
de la república han sido azotados por
las fuertes lluvias provocadas por
fenómenos meteorológicos como enrique y
elsa la más reciente tromba que pegó en
el estado de mexico dejó más de 400
viviendas con daños y más de mil
damnificados las lluvias inundaron el
hospital general de atizapán de zaragoza
y todos los pacientes tuvieron que ser
trasladados a otras unidades médicas
el pronóstico indica que seguirá
lloviendo
[Música]
brasil padece la peor crisis hídrica del
siglo que amenaza el funcionamiento de
muchas centrales hidroeléctricas y por
consecuencia el suministro de
electricidad algunos expertos temen un
colapso energético y que se tenga que
llegar a racionar la electricidad un
escenario que el gobierno desmiente otro
peligro son los incendios forestales que
en los últimos años han asolado la
amazonia y también el pantanal que el
año pasado perdió por causa del fuego el
26 por ciento de sus biomas la
preocupación por esa coyuntura dice que
más incendios es tan grande que jair
bolsonaro el presidente de brasil ha
firmado este mes un decreto que prohíbe
el fuego controlado hasta finales de
octubre las personas que quieran quemar
áreas verdes para designarlas a pasto a
la agricultura tendrán que tener un
permiso especial de los órganos
ambientales
[Música]